meine These ist dass eben das dass wir
leider Gottes die sehr viele sehr
schlüssige Befunde haben dass ich dass
ich junge Menschen in unserer
Gesellschaft
überfordert fühlen und das viele
irgendwie auch diese diese Zuspitzungen
des in der Gesellschaft permanent gibt
also eher skeptisch betrachten also vor
allem und das ist jetzt wieder das Thema
auch für den Politiker hier unter uns es
gibt da relativ große Distanzierung von
der von der Politik also das ist da muss
man den deutschen noch gratulieren
möchte ich aus Österreicher derzeit 22
Jahre schon da liegt da ist es nicht so
schlimm wie in Österreich also in
Deutschland haben wir immerhin 50%, die
zum Beispiel noch den den Politik der
etablierten Politik Vertrauen in
Österreich ist das nur mein Drittel wir
haben und und weil wir zuerst diesen
diese kurzes kurze Geplänkel wegen den
sozialen Unterschichten gehabt haben was
wir sehen in unseren Studien und das
betrifft auch vor allem die Jugend dass
sich die Jugend aus dem Gesellschafts
Drittel ja aus der unteren Hälfte der
Gesellschaft immer mehr von der Politik
zurückziehen und das Angebot nicht
wahrnehmen an der Politik teilzunehmen
das ist die Wellen nicht das heißt wir
haben oben wir haben eine eine Kultur
wir gehen einer Kultur entgegen wo die
bildungsnahen und die die
sozialprivilegierten ihre Politik wählen
und die unteren sich immer mehr davon
zurückziehen dass sie für höchst
problematisch problematisch halte weil
wir dann dann und das wird jetzt die
Frage der nächsten Zeit sein sehen
werden ob diese Leute noch still halten
werden wenn die Probleme die jetzt auf
Sie zukommen nicht und das ist vor allem
Inflation und teurer wenn die drückend
werden weil wenn die in ein politisches
System integriert werden und werden und
das Gefühl haben damit gestalten zu
können wäre das nicht zu problematisch
wenn sie aber neben dem System stehen
dann kann das kann das durchaus zu
vorübergehend anonymischen Zuständen
führen und davor würde ich warnen Jugend
glaubt ja nicht mehr nicht mehr an die
Politik auch der Journalismus hat es
sehr schwer bei der Jugend die Medien
auch da ist großer Einbruch in im
Vertrauen was wäre denn ihr
Lösungsansatz also sie haben jetzt ja
mit der in der Beck ein FDP-Politiker
sitzen wo sehen Sie den Lösungsansatz
die Jugend zurück zu gewinnen der Jugend
Hoffnung zu geben dann muss ich Ihnen
recht geben das ist bei den Medien und
bei den Journalisten ist wirklich das
Problem das ist offensichtlich ist und
ich sage das jetzt immer so unheimlich
dabei dass dem Fenster raus dass das
wirklich eine Veranstaltung von einer
sehr engen engen Bevölkerungsgruppe ist
und wenn man jetzt sie haben gesagt sie
hören immer den Radiosender denn den den
Deutschlandfunk Deutschlandfunk und ich
fahre auch wenn ich Fragen nach acht
Stunden mit dem Auto fahre komme ich am
Ende an haben gesagt ich habe eine
gehirner eine Gehirnwäsche hinter mir
und ich glaube das ist die Problematik
das ganze System ist dieses ganze
Mediensystem ist zu abgehoben und und
repräsentiert die Interessen dieser
Leute da unten nicht mehr und da würde
ich mir wirklich schnell was überlegen
weil da kannst durchaus zu Problemen und
Verwerfungen kommen können Sie gerne den
Deutschlandfunk
selten weil ich komme gleich dazu
richtig Radio zu hören also ich lass
immer Presse lesen und wenn sie auf die
Presse die ich ausgewählt habe und das
ist auch teilweise das ist das ist dann
teilweise auch ein Problem und ich finde
auch in der Tat ist es so diese schnelle
Medienwelt diese wirklich enorm schnelle
Medienwelt wir können auch uns mal wir
können uns auch immer nur medienmäßig
auf eine Sache konzentrieren früher hat
man das immer als ich aufgewachsen bin
hatten wir immer drei vier Sachen die
nebeneinander diskutiert worden sind wir
können das immer nur noch mit einer
machen weil das alles so stört da müssen
wir auch alles wissen da müssen wir auch
das letzte noch unter dem letzten Stein
vorholen und auch die letzte
Ausnahmesituation sozusagen rauskitzeln
und ich glaube dass irritiert auch
Jugendliche und Jugendliche verstehen
dann diese einfachen Headlines die
einfach auch polarisieren sind zum Teil
die verstehen die denn die können sie
nicht so richtig nachvollziehen und
nachgreifen weil sie wissen das komplett
soll ich will sagen aus meiner Erfahrung
als Abgeordneter ich habe ja sehr viele
Besuchergruppen auch auch gerade
Schülergruppen wenn man so ein
Kontingent für 250 Schüler in den
Deutschen Bundestag zu holen mit denen
zu sprechen und so weiter und alle und
ich besuche auch sehr viel Schule in
meinem Wahlkreis und das sind immer die
schönsten Veranstaltung weil sie auf
einmal merken die Jugendlichen sind gar
nicht um politisch aber sie haben
einfach keine Lust mehr auf diesen
Konsum den wir hier einfach an Medien
zum großen Teil haben und wenn ich mit
denen rede sind das erfrischende
Diskussionen und die sind auch
unglaublich wissbegierig und ich würde
auf keinen Fall sagen dass die Jugend
nicht mehr so politisch ist und ich habe
gerade auch aus einem Berg ich komme aus
dem Ruhrgebiet da gibt es ja nun auch
die ein oder andere Problemschule und
ich habe auch eine Hauptschule bei mir
mal gehabt und das war eine der
wunderbarsten Gespräche die ich geführt
habe mit Jugendlichen teilweise mit
Migration
ja ja
ist es so schön wie hier gesagt wird die
Schulen die Lehrer wenn die Schulen da
sitzen die Klassen ich muss zum Beispiel
sagen ich lerne das geht kann euch für
alle Erzieher am wenigstens an euch drei
geht es ich lerne allen Klassen ab der
fünften man lässt die Leute Ausreden man
unterbricht niemanden
aber okay gut vielleicht darf ich jetzt
mal ohne unterbrochen zu werden ich habe
in der Schule gelernt kurz und bündig
nicht zu lange Monologe ja kurz und
knapp doch das sage ich auch bei
aufsetzen das stimmt schon und man kann
dann zum Punkt kommen was ich aktuell
andere vielleicht jetzt hier eher
weniger aber gut okay nur mal ein paar
Songs sie finden mich euch immer in die
Exkurse rein okay auf jeden Fall doch
ist es also ich liebe das auch mit den
Schülern zu diskutieren ich habe ja
deutsch englisch also insofern da bin
ich sowieso ständig am Diskutieren und
das macht mega viel Spaß natürlich und
die Schüler lassen sie auch Ausreden da
bin ich mir ganz sicher
ich möchte jetzt nicht ihre
beeindruckende journalistische Laufbahn
hier aufzählen sonst brauche ich auch
noch länger als die Sendung ist aber sie
als Experte zu bezeichnen ich glaube das
ist ein Journalismus nicht übertrieben
wie hat sich denn die Medienwelt
verändert Wir haben hier gerade gehört
es gab früher drei Themen jetzt nur noch
ein Thema wie nehmen sie es denn weil
sind die Mädchen schlechter geworden
stattfindet das heißt die Tendenz im
häppchenjournalismus es wird also in
kurzer Zeit werden un ständig
Informationen über hitzerweise über die
Menschen hereingegossen viele
Jugendliche und ich habe die orientiere
ausgebildet viele Jahre lang konnte von
Jahr zu Jahr feststellen wie sich das
Niveau verschlechtert das Denken in
Kausalitäten lässt enorm nach auch die
Sprachfähigkeit das heißt also dieses
den Genuss der Sprache auszuschöpfen und
Sachverhalte umfassend darzustellen ist
nahezu mittlerweile auf ein rudimentären
stand zurückgefallen 20 Prozent aller
Grundschüler in der Bundesrepublik sind
nicht in der Lage satt gewisse
Satzstellungen zu bilden Sätze mit dem
Infinitiv mit zu und enthaupten
Nebensatz zu unterscheiden das ist eine
Katastrophe das ist eine Rückentwicklung
in Zeiten des Mittelalters entschuldigen
das ist ja so sage es gibt in Berlin
mittlerweile Kurse Telefonate zu lernen
und frei zu sprechen und nicht mehr nur
tipp tipp tipp zu machen sondern mal ein
wirklich Satz voll zu artikulieren und
die Gegenantwort abzuwachen das Problem
ist Journalismus
in erlebt es ja vor entschuldigen Sie
ich kenne jeder Sitzung die ich Gott sei
Dank muss ich keiner mehr führen aber
dass die Leute sitzen und selbst da
nicht wirklich nicht und dauernd wird
unterbrochen die besteht nicht die
Fähigkeit mehr als 6 7 Sätze überhaupt
anzuhören die wollen Sie denn dann zu
einem abgewogenen Meinungsbild kommen
halte ich für ausgeschlossen es gibt
Schüler die gar nicht mehr in
klassisches Buch lesen von dem Klassiker
Egmond oder so nicht oder Fontane die
begeister die begreifen was semantisch
gar nicht mehr nämlich keine Vorwurf den
ich den Macher die sagen was soll der
Quatsch warum soll ich diese
Schlüsselsatz lesen das halte ich für
eine Katastrophe ich habe jetzt seit
drei Söhne und auch ein Enkel bereits
bin sehr glücklich mit meinen Kindern
davon abgesehen ich habe den jetzt ein
Buch gestellt von fernheim von Schirach
das heißt ich will keine Werbung machen
aber das heißt Zigaretten und Kaffee es
sind so kleine kleiner Aphorismen und
nicht länger als zwei Seiten und da habe
ich gesagt guckt euch das mal an was
Sprache vom Markt auf einer Seite mehr
als ein Gemälde mehr als 3 Stunden tat
also wieso zum kotzen aber verstehen Sie
was ich meine das ist wir vergessen die
Erziehung der Gefühle die Erziehung des
Umgangs mit Sprache und Informationen
werden ich finde sie sagen viele
richtige Sachen also es ist anders das
richtig war mit dem Gehalt
gewaltthaltigen migrantischen Milieus es
gibt einige das ist und das finde ich es
auch richtig also das Problem dass wir
jetzt haben ist Punkt 1 das Bild
erschlägt die Sprache also das haben wir
das logische Instrument der Sprache die
argumentiert die wird eigentlich durch
das Bild weggewischt und die Sprache
steht nicht beim Vordergrund dass das
Bilder ansehen und das zweite ist dass
diese nervöse Gesellschaft in den in der
wir leben dazu führt dass die jungen
Menschen die Fähigkeit so Aufmerksamkeit
verlieren also das heißt die patention
sie haben das angeführt dass das
Fachvokabular dafür dass ich wirklich
also mein Gott den Mann ohne
Eigenschaften zu lesen oder sowas
Schlusswort heute mit der aufmerksam